[Musik]
es ist die Schocknachricht des Tages
bASF will weg aus Deutschland tausende
Arbeitsplätze sind in Gefahr zusätzlich
drängen immer mehr Flüchtlinge ins Land
und es drohen auch noch neue
corona-maßnahmen ist Deutschland
eigentlich noch zu retten das sind
unsere Themen und damit herzlich
willkommen hier bei Viertel nach 8 mit
diesen spannenden Gästen Sängerinnen und
silly Frontfrau Julia Neigel der Abgang
von BASF sei Haus gemacht sagt sie die
Politik habe auf ganzer Linie versagt
enttäuscht von unserer Regierung ist
auch eher Medienmanager Hans maar Scholz
lasse sich von Putin erpressen und zwar
mit Flüchtlingen die könnten wir uns
aber langfristig nicht mehr leisten noch
weniger leisten können wir uns den
Corona Irrsinn von Karl Lauterbach sagt
Arzt und Bestsellerautor dr Gunther
Frank impfen kann töten so seine These
ja tot ist Deutschland aber eh schon und
zwar emotional das sagt Publizist Georg
Gaffron depressives Deutschland also
darüber müssen wir auf jeden Fall
diskutieren schön dass Sie alle da sind
so und wir beginnen mit Frau Neigel sie
sind nämlich aus Ludwigshafen ihre ganze
Region die droht jetzt eben durch den
Abgang von BASF ja sich aufzulösen sagen
sie das ist eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe
aber das ist offensichtlich nur der
Anfang sagen sie ich bin gespannt auf
Ihre These bitte schön legen Sie los
also ich bin aus Ludwigshafen ich wohne
da schon viele Jahre und ein Konzern ob
man ihn mag oder nicht wie die BASF
bringt natürlich Wohlstand und
Arbeitsplätze und
die Sanktionen die stattgefunden haben
auch diese exorbitanten Gas und
Energiepreise haben jetzt bei BASF
zugeschlagen mit 2,2 Milliarden
Zusatzkosten das muss man sich einfach
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen was das
für für eine Summe ist dass es Wucher
nach dem Völkerrecht darf man einem Volk
die Existenzgrundlage nicht in 10 das
ist Artikel 1 Absatz 2 Satz 2 im icsca
und in iccpa und ich sehe schon seit
Monaten zu wie immer wieder die
Pleitewelle per Titel Überschrift und
aufzeigen kommt und sehe diese
Entspanntheit im Bundestag kein Mensch
spricht darüber in Herr Habig sagt naja
wenn die Produktion sind wir haben es ja
gehört wenn die Produktion eingestellt
wird ist das noch lange keine Insolvenz
ich sehe auch schon in dieser Stadt also
in Ludwigshafen und ich denke die ist
repräsentativ für viele Industriestädte
eine öde ganz viele Geschäfte haben
zugemacht ein großer Investor hat ein
riesen EInkaufszentrum übernommen aber
aus dem Ausland und der Mittelstand
bricht in sich zusammen ich laufe Gassi
sehe Rentner die im Müll wählen und
Flaschen suchen um sich ihr ihre schmale
Rente zu verbessern ich sehe eine Flut
von Flüchtlingen in dieser Stadt und ich
glaube das ist repräsentativ ist für die
für die den gesamten Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und ich fordere die Politik
auch mit diesem Wahnsinn aufzuhören weil
das ist eine die und die
Industrialisierung die diese
Volkswirtschaft zerstören wird was hat
die Politik denn ihrer Meinung nach in
diesem Fall falsch gemacht woran liegt
das
also die Politik scheint sich immer mehr
für das im Außen zu interessieren als an
das Wohl der eigenen Bevölkerung sie sie
haben eine Sanktionspolitik durchgeführt
die letztendlich zu diesem Chaos geführt
hat viele andere Staaten haben das
offensichtlich nicht die kaufen nämlich
zum Beispiel russisches Gas und
verkaufen es noch Deutschland und zwar
für viel teureres Geld als wir es hätten
so haben können Herr Gaffron Sanktionen
lieber weg als sanktions
nicht folgen die Ursachen für die wir
heute ausbaden liegen ja ganz woanders
das heißt also wenn ich mich so abhängig
mache wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
von einem Lieferanten 55 Prozent und den
Russen von denen jederzeit Jahren weiß
dass sie weder einen Rechtsstaat sind
noch eine nicht aggressive Außenpolitik
betreiben das konnten sie ja schon sehen
bei dem Annektion von apassion und
südostizien in Georgien das konnten sie
sehen bei der Krim und das sehen wir
jetzt wieder das heißt wir sind bewusst
in eine gefährliche Lage hineingetrieben
oder durch Blindheit und jetzt zahlt
sich das aus ein Land das zu mal aus der
Atomenergie einfach aussteigt ohne ein
Ersatz dafür zu haben ohne die jetzt
weiterlaufen
Atomkraft von Madame merkel war der ist
der Grundfehler unseres heutigen
disasters ohne das zu Ende
das ist nicht so die Kausalitäten sind
ein bisschen anders und ich finde
Auffassung wir hätten auch wenn die
Abhängigkeit von Russland und ich muss
auch ein bisschen was sagen gegen die
regierungsschelte wir haben es immerhin
geschafft dass wir die gastbehälter die
werden Russen verkauft haben gefüllt
haben dieses Land ist nicht taub und
auch Dynamik ich werde mich einfach
dagegen dass wir unser Land so
runtermachen die Bundesrepublik Tag und
Nacht machen sich Leute Gedanken wie
doch das haben sie gerade gemacht und
das finde ich auch das ist Bild von
Hungernden Rentnern die da irgendwo im
aber das ist doch nicht die
Bundesrepublik waren sie am Flughafen
sind Ferienbeginn 70.000 Leute sind vom
Flughafen Tegel weggeflogen in den
Urlaub aber das ist jetzt nicht der
Ernst ich laufe jeden Tag Gassi mit
meinem Hund sie jeden Tag Rentner die im
Müll will und die ganzen
Hund ja aber damit zu tun
nicht raus und schauen Sie sich morgens
irgendwann mal oder zu Hause und ich bin
in Wien zu Hause und ich bin in Berlin
zu Hause muss ehrlich sagen also es ist
überall einigermaßen in Ordnung die muss
ehrlich sagen man kann immer noch stolz
sein dass man in Deutschland
also es gibt schon viele Viertel in
vielen Städten also wenn ich abends so
durch Neukölln laufe als Gast hier ja
und an meine Sprache erkennen müssen wir
vielleicht ich bin ja nicht aus
Deutschland über zwei deutsche Mutter
aber aber einen österreichischen Pfad
und komme aus Wien also was wir in
Deutschlands auf die Nerven geht ist das
schlechtmachen des eigenen Landes das
ist doch schrecklich aber das Furcht
ja es gibt Arme Viertel aber
wenn man jede jede jede jedes
Unternehmen ja das in sich versagt hat
ja und dann einen Anlass nimmt nämlich
die Energieverteilung um irgendetwas zu
machen woanders hinzugehen wo das
übrigens auch nicht viel billiger ist ja
da muss man nämlich sagen bitte schauen
uns aber die Firmen an das ist mein
ernst nehmen Sie die den nehmen Sie den
Hakel für den hakelbetrieb ja
toilettepapier jeder kauft
Toilettenpapier und plötzlich in der
tolle Firma kaputt
Deutschland es liegt an den
Energiekosten hier können wir so nicht
mehr wenn sie doch nach Frankreich da
ist es was weiß ich um einiges günstiger
sie kaufen russisches Gas zum Beispiel
es liegt am Standort Deutschland schon
vor Corona und dieser Energie dieser
ukraine-krise haben etliche deutsche
Firmen auch Autokonzerne den Abbau von
100.000 Arbeitsplätzen angekündigt
werden wir im internationalen Wettbewerb
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind das
sind doch alles hausgemacht das
Standorts Deutschland aber es ist doch
nicht okay aber das ist doch nicht okay
in ihrer Praxis merken sie dass das
zugenommen hat dass es eine
Wohlstandsverwahrlosung sozusagen gibt
fühlen sich die Menschen von der Politik
allein gelassen also es gibt natürlich
immer die die tatsächlichen Zahlen es
gibt die gefühlte Wirklichkeit aber ich
muss sagen beides ich würde ich schon
sagen beides hat bei vielen meiner
Patienten schon zu Existenzängsten
geführt und ich habe auch Selbstständige
die auch aufgehört haben ich glaube wir
reden halt letztendlich über eine
Entwicklung die nachher kann ich das
auch mit Kofi zusammenbringen damit
zusammenhängt dass wir in Deutschland
uns angewöhnt haben einfach gegen
Sachverstand zu entscheiden welches die
Energie Sache zum Beispiel sehe ist das
jetzt glaube ich so acht Jahre her da
haben die Professoren des physikalischen
Instituts in Heidelberg eine
Stellungnahme zur Energiewende gebracht
da steht genau das drin was jetzt
eingetreten ist und keiner hat sich
dafür interessiert ich habe die
Rhein-Neckar-Zeitung gefragt und
Heidelberg bringt das doch das ist doch
vor der Haustür die Uni das doch
interessant nein es hat keinen
interessiert waren alle in ihrem waren
waren man kann alles abschalten und mit
Windkraft und erneuerbaren ersetzen
jetzt haben wir halt die Quittung und
das ist jetzt man hätte nur damit
beginnen müssen
die Alternative war natürlich dass man
nach dem Einstellen oder dem Auslaufen
des
atomenergiebedarf dass man dann etwas
anderes aufbaut damit hat man zu spät
begonnen da hat man nichts gemacht
und das ist das
poliertem Fahrstuhl vergessen
dann zeigt aber die Frage ist wie geht's
denn jetzt weiter wird es jetzt ist es
der Anfang vom Ende BASF werden jetzt
weitere Firmen abwandern sind wir auf
einer downwärtsspirale ganz ganz
sicherlich nicht ganz sicherlich nicht
das werden schwierige Möglichkeiten gar
keine Frage es ist verdammt einmal nicht
leichter zu produzieren in den im UK
oder in Frankreich das ist doch alles
eine Irrtum ja natürlich kann man
leichter wir haben da schon einmal
vorher diskutiert darüber in Amerika
produzieren weil dort die Energie Teere
billiger ist weil sie sich selbst
beziehen und selbst herstellen können
aber das alles downwärts geht aber auch
ohne russisches Gas wird es auch ohne
russisches Gas so bleiben wie es ist
oder
unserer Gesellschaft ist stark genug
unsere Kreativität und die Köpfe die
hier sind dieses zu meistern und die
Kraft herunter Marktwirtschaft und der
hier tätigen Kräfte und nicht dieses
marode Russland die das einzige was ihr
haben verscheuern ihre Rohstoffe sonst
haben sie nämlich
genau wegen dieser Gaskrise eben die
Unternehmen sagen sie können nicht mehr
produzieren deshalb Menschen entlassen
werden und ähnliches was soll man denn
jetzt machen wir wollen wir das denn
jetzt auf der auf die Schnelle
ausgleichen wer ist da wirklich jetzt
daran Schuld der Gaspreis in der
Zwischenzeit ist in der vor
ukraine-krise das ist und wieso ist aber
so ja also da gibt schon noch mehr zu
klären sie genauso wie beim Benzinpreis
komischerweise steigt der Benzinpreis
immer dann wenn Schulferien sind und
zwar dramatisch
gestaltete Kapitalismus der hier zum
Ausdrucken wer ist denn Schulter dann
dran was sind denn das für Mechanismen
die dahinter stehen natürlich
kapitalistische Mechanismen
marktwirtschaftlicher Mechanismen die
von einer Regierung auch ein bisschen
eingebremst werden muss und deswegen hat
die EU eingeschritten und wird
hoffentlich einschreiten aber das geht
nur für die extreme ich bin im Gottes
Willen kein nicht Kapitalist ja oder
oder kein Anti marktwirtschafter aber
nur alles kann man nicht wahrnehmen
in Erhöhung an Strom und und Gaspreisen
nicht mit ganz normalen kapitalistischen
Interessen verbinden das ist wahnsinnten
Interesse ja Wahnsinns Preise
zwei Herren
mit Frau neige spazieren gehen also ich
meine ich glaube ich denke schon dass
das erschreckende Bilder teilweise sind
und ich glaube dass ihre Wahrnehmung da
schon auch ein bisschen ich will Ihnen
speziell ist ich will immer etwas sagen
ich war glauben Sie das ist eine elitäre
Meinung ich habe viele Jahre in den USA
gelebt in Detroit ist als Autostadt vor
die Hunde gegangen war wie ein Ghost
Town denn sie heute hinkommen ist eine
prosperierende
it-metropole geworden weil der tüchtige
Menschen die nicht Jammer gejammert
haben sondern gesagt don't talk about it
no problem is only
solutionieren
sie haben Recht aber Sie müssen erstmal
die Flaschen feuern und die Fähigen dran
lassen das ist der Punkt
da haben wir gerade so ist
die USA Deutschland das hängt ja noch
mal an irgendein gar kein Gesundheit
Sozialsystem ähnliches wir haben ein
ganz anderes
ist einfach falsch
wer keine Arbeit haben
aber nie arbeitslos glaube ich da ich
bin Unternehmer ja genau Sache mit der
Pflichtversicherung dort nicht notwendig
braucht man eine Zwangsversicherung
30% der Amerikaner sind entweder nicht
oder unterversichert und die können
nicht ins Spital gehen und ins
Krankenhaus
wollen Sie solche Verhältnisse auch bei
uns also eine Segel bekannte
Fluchtbewegung aus den USA ist mir nicht
bekannt und dass man festzuhalten ja es
hatten Amerikaner hier Asyl beantragt
ich glaube wir werden keinen finden
erstmal um das zu sagen die meisten
Menschen die ich kenne Leben dort sehr
gut und sehr wohl und vor allen Dingen
frei frei aber auch die Menschen die sie
kennen und es gibt eben einen großen
Anteil glaube ich an Amerikanern die
nicht so glücklich sind mit ihrer
Situation und sehr gerne
einer meiner Musiker ist Amerika
auch noch die auch noch wir haben schon
genau gleich dazu
Existenzängste sind trotzdem ein Problem
was uns hier begleitet in Deutschland
nicht nur in Amerika auch hier haben sie
und das sind keine Illusionen was
erleben was erleben Sie sie sagen ja nun
sie haben auch viele Freunde Bekannte
die zum Beispiel bei Baska BASF arbeiten
immer wieder zu dem Beispiel
zurückzukommen was bedeutet das jetzt
für die das ist für die einfachen Horror
das ist eine Katastrophe weil wenn die
einfach ihren Job davon leben ja ganze
Familien dann dann steht
wer hat denn Lust auf diesen Sozialstaat
indem er sich bei Hartz IV anreißt das
ist doch vollkommen Geld wissen Sie
überhaupt dass wenn Sie ein Haus haben
lassen sie sich zwei Kinder zwei Autos
und 150.000 Vermögen haben Sie Anspruch
auf Bürgergeld das ist die Realität zu
definiert dieser Pflanze
die Menschen haben Angst es sind sehr
sehr viele die schon ihre Geschäfte auch
geschlossen haben während des lockdowns
die haben das nicht überstanden wie
gesagt ich habe vorhin von diesen
Einkaufsstraßen geredet die sind leer
und jetzt haben sie noch größere Angst
und diese Stadt hat nun mal einfach
dieses Zentrum das ist einfach der
größte einnahmebereich und die BASF ist
vor allen Dingen auch zuständig für
Grundstoffe die Sie weitergeben für
weitere Produktionsketten in der
Umgebung da gibt es ja andere
Unternehmen das heißt es bedrohten
gesamten eine gesamte Region und darüber
hinaus wir machen eine ganz neue Pause
an dieser Stelle atme mal einmal ganz
kurz durch wir machen aber dann auch
gleich stark weiter es geht um das Thema
Flüchtlinge die Menschen in der Ukraine
die haben natürlich ganz andere Ängste
aber Hans Maar der sagt ja Putin nutzt
das aus und er pretzt uns mit den
Flüchtlingen und damit geht eben auch
sein Konzept voll auf mehr dazu gleich
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei Viertel acht fünf Köpfen fünf
Meinungen vor jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jörg ist wir
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rumbußen
die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu wichtig
uns nur der AFD zu überlassen lass den
Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatal ist in der
Politik bei den Journalisten deren Job
ist es doch gerade abweichende Meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig doof finden
vielleicht einmal kurz anders also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall meine lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
dittis ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt
mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
durch die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
weiter geht's hier bei viertel nach acht
und wir machen gleich spannend weiter
Hans Mahr hat eine sehr interessante
These nämlich das Putin uns mit den
Flüchtlingen erpresst wie genauer das
meint das erzählt er uns jetzt mal das
ist leicht nachzuweisen aber vielleicht
ein Einstieg nur wissen Sie eigentlich
wie viele Flüchtlinge schon in ötten in
Deutschland leben drei Millionen
Flüchtlinge das heißt jeder dritte bis
vierte unter 1000 ist ein Flüchtling der
hier lebt in Deutschland ich hasse nicht
zu sehr wie den blöden Saga von das Boot
ist voll das Boot ist nicht voll aber es
ist in stürmischer See und wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht sinken wir
können das nicht so hinnehmen auf die
Dauer denn wir können nicht auf unsere
demokratische Gesellschaft verzichten
und die kommt in Gefahr wenn wir
überborden woher kommt das das kommt
daher weil Putin der Kriegsmeister
uns damit erpresst indem er überall dort
wo der bombardiert dort geht Flüchtlinge
und die werden dann am besten nach
Deutschland geschickt das war im Syrien
so das ist jetzt in der Ukraine so und
so speit sich langsam ein ganzer Berg
von drei Millionen Flüchtlingen und es
werden mehr und mehr von Tag zu Tag auf
das kann so nicht weitergehen das kann
auf die Dauer auch nicht gut gehen das
heißt aber was können wir tun und da
gibt es nur eine Möglichkeit Waffen
liefern damit der ganze Wahnsinn
permanent weitergeht das ist nicht die
einzige Lösung wir müssen schauen dass
wir Frieden schaffen auf jedem Art und
Möglichkeiten schauen dass wir die
Friedensbewegung oder
Friedensverhandlungen dort möglich
machen das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
dass es wirklich auch für uns zu
ertragen geht nicht nur das was sie
sagen dass die Energiepreis und die
ganze Politik und die ganze Wirtschaft
wieder funktioniert sondern dass wir
diese Flüchtlingsproblematik auch in den
Griff bekommen okay das finde ich sehr
spannend Frieden schaffen mit Putin das
ist ja nur eigentlich das was im Grunde
genommen alle irgendwie wollen man will
Frieden für die Ukraine aber Frieden mit
Putin wie kann man sich das vorstellen
mit ihm reden nicht wie soll das
funktionieren ich glaube es gibt ein
gutes Beispiel das auch so zum
selenskischen genannt worden ist
Österreich war nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg so wie auch Deutschland von
vier Mächten besetzt und hat mit den
Russen damals durchgesetzt durch die
selbst deklarierte
Unabhängigkeit durch die selbst
dekorierte Neutralität das ist ein
unabhängiger Staat geworden ist das war
auch nicht so leicht und nicht so
einfach weil wir waren damals genau wie
heute Ukraine an der Grenze zwischen den
beiden Systemen und das ist nicht nur
gut gegangen sondern das kann durchaus
auch für die Ukraine eine Möglichkeit
sein ich sage nur einen Satz noch dazu
dann gleich kommt gleich der Kollege
Gaffron wenn der schaut so böse aus und
will was ganz anderes sagen
ich kann mich auch auf jemanden der
vielleicht nicht das links Seins und so
weiter verdächtig ist
Henry Kissinger
hat gesagt unsere Kissinger hat gesagt
und zwar schon vor zehn Jahren die
Ukraine
it's a perfect Buffer state hat wir
brauchen unbedingt in der NATO wir
brauchen sie
Ukraine jetzt als Pufferstaat als
Pufferstaat für Russland und zwischen
Russland und der NATO preisgeben wäre
das auch also ihre Taktik also dass wir
einfach über andere Völker wie das
ukrainische hier am Tisch einfach
urteilen als sei dass eine Schachfigur
wenn sie nicht parieren gehen Sie in die
russische Knechtschaft oder bleiben
Moral was auch immer die Ukraine ist ein
souveräner in der Vereinten Nationen
Mitglied es ist garantiert worden
1998 in den Vereinbarungen und 2008 dass
die Ukraine souverän ist dass sie einen
Schutz genießt und so weiter also
die Russen haben ein schweres
Völkerrechtsverbrechen begangen hier
besteht ganz eindeutige Klarheit und ich
kann ihnen eins sagen die
haben gesagt
1900 39 als Hitler Polen eigentlich
Vergleiche Hitler mit Putin um das da zu
sagen denn in dem Moment als die Nazis
Polen angegriffen haben gab es einen
Beistandspakt zwischen der Franz
Frankreich und Polen dann hieß es in
Paris für Danzig sterben nein acht
Monate später marschierte Hitler durch
den Triumphbogen in Paris das ist die
Antwort
durch totalitäre Mächte und deren Logik
und der ist nicht mit kuschen weil sie
sagen mit Putin kann man nicht reden
Tango tanzen gehören zwei der will ja
nicht mal aufs Tanzfläche gehen jedes
Gespräch ab wie stellen Sie sich denn
eine Friedenslösung vor wir müssen dem
Russen zeigen dass Völkerrecht existiert
wir müssen zeigen wir Deutschen zeigen
wieder den Russen etwas
Rolle
dann gibt sie Vereinigten Staaten
Österreich übrigens seine salonrolle da
tanzen weiter könnten sie nur von dem
Hintergrund der NATO und der starken
Bundesrepublik das ist doch eine
salon-diba Nummer die sie abziehen dabei
sein Land das nur von dem festen
Garantie des westlichen Bündnisses
existieren kann und diese schaukelrolle
eingenommen hat also Österreich ist dann
so sie sind sie sind ich bin
Russlanddeutsche
Mentalität würden sie das auch so
unterstreichen würden Sie sagen ja nee
mit Putin kann man nicht reden oder kann
man doch ich bin keine Russin ich bin
mit fünf Jahren nach Deutschland
gekommen weil wir Deutsche sind ich
kenne die Mentalität der Russen
eigentlich nur aus der persönlichen
Sicht das sind ganz freundlicher und
sehr herzliche sehr sehr emotionale
Leute was da politisch geschieht da
steige ich nicht so durch ich bin kein
geopolitiker was ich aber in all den
Jahren für mich persönlich immer
propagandiert habe ist
abrüsten abrüsten abrüsten was mich sehr
stört und ich weiß ihr werdet es über
mich herfallen ist dass Deutschland
mittlerweile ich glaube der fünf größte
rüstungsexporteur ist und
Rüstungsexporte Waffen erzeugen in
Krisen Flüchtlinge und das ist einfach
eine Tatsache
darf ich darf ich auch dazu sagen dass
Flüchtlinge schaffen ja der Krieg in der
Ukraine schon etwas länger geht als
dieser wirklich schreckliche aber ein
Fall der geht schon seit 2014 da gab es
das Massaker Notdienst gehen Sie also
mit Hand gehen sie mit mit
uns erpresst mit Flüchtling ich glaube
dass das Putin eigentlich überhaupt
nicht darum geht ich glaube das ganz
andere Sorgen gerade das empfinden wir
so aber das haben wir damals auch
empfunden als es in Syrien so war ich
glaube wir müssen aufhören Waffen zu
liefern Ihnen alle möglichen Gebiete ich
glaube wir müssen aufhören mit Krieg
Geld zu machen ich glaube wir sollten
mal auf Artikel 20 das zivilpakt 1
gucken wir dürfen nicht in Krieg
investieren am eher im Artikel 1
Grundgesetz Absatz 2 steht drin wir
sollten dem Frieden der Welt dienen ich
glaube wir müssten eine Friedenspolitik
machen wir müssen Verhandlungen führen
wir müssen dafür sorgen als eine mit
beiden Parteien wir müssen die dazu
kriegen dass die miteinander sprechen
miteinander sprechen das ist das was
viele Jahrzehnte lang viele Politiker
gemacht haben und wir kamen
ist das wirklich eine friedensrolle die
ja da treibt ich habe ja das Gefühl dass
Erdogan eher nur für sich selber seine
eigenen Interessen durchsetzen
durchsetzen
haben Sie das Gefühl herr Frank kümmern
wir uns zu sehr um die anderen und
weniger um uns selbst
also bei diesem Thema fällt es mir
schwer etwas zu sagen weil ich auch sehr
schwanke ich ich höre ihnen plausibel
ich höre ihnen zu ist plausibel
was ich ziehe mich dann immer ein
bisschen zurück auf meinen auf meinen
Max Weber der ihm gesagt hat bedenke das
Ende also eben Verantwortungsethik und
dass man halt schaut vielleicht
dass man zu sehr hier außerhalb des
Kriegs
mit einer Art gratismut etwas fordert
und vielleicht überdenkt oder übersieht
dass letztendlich die Bevölkerung Gottes
ausbaden muss aber ich bin da wirklich
kein Experte ich weiß dass meine
Patienten die teilweise auch aus dem Don
Bass kommen das sehr unterschiedlich
sehen ich was berichten
das sollten Sie selber sagen weil ich
möchte das auch jetzt gar nicht ich weil
ich bin nicht gefestigt in dieser
Meinung ich kann jetzt nicht sagen die
haben teilweise eine andere Sichtweise
wie zum Beispiel Medien hier ich kann
aber nicht beurteilen ob sie an der
Propaganda unterliegen wahrscheinlich
ich weiß alle miteinander
differenzierter oft gesehen wird und das
einzige wo ich jetzt vielleicht hier
beitragen könnte ist noch mal der Appell
dass man nicht die Position vertritt was
fühlt sich jetzt richtig an sondern dass
man wirklich auch bedenkt was kommt raus
ganz kurze Frage nochmal zum Thema
Flüchtlinge zu denen die auch kommen und
die hier sind aus der Ukraine könnte
nicht vielleicht auch eine Chance sein
in Zeiten von Fachkräftemangel wenn man
jetzt zum Beispiel auch sieht wir haben
großen Ärztemangel auf dem Land
Pflegekräfte ähnliches kann das nicht
vielleicht auch eine Chance für uns sein
also ich glaube das wird die Leute die
wir brauchen im Moment nicht bekommen
zum Beispiel aus der Ukraine das soll
aber nicht negativ sein ich habe ein
großes Herz für Flüchtlinge wir müssen
nur auch ab und zu mal an uns selber
denken also und jeder und was mir
meisten zu nerven geht ist ob das jetzt
der Ministerpräsident Kretschmer ist der
sagt also Friedensverhandlungen und in
dem Moment wo man Friedensverhandlungen
nur den Mund nimmt ist man schon ein
putinfreiheit nein das sind sich gut im
Freien das sind Menschen
auf Verantwortung das ist eine große
Kontroverse Verantwortung geht nicht ja
natürlich Ethik schon gelernt
Nachrüstung ja es ist so Helmut Schmidt
hat auch schon gegeben ja und vorher bei
Plato auch schon wenn
Sie die antike Geschichte auch einmal
als eine aber zum Beispiel sagt
Rüstung lange in die Geschichte gehen
Ich will noch Folgendes sagen wir müssen
ein bisschen differenzieren es gibt
Kriegsflüchtlinge und es gibt Asylanten
Kriegsflüchtlinge die unter Bedrohungen
sind müssen aufgenommen werden das ist
eine fester Status in uno Dokumenten
festgelegt und den menschenrechts-
Topf mit Gas beschossen werden von den
Russen im übrigen oder ob sie aus der
Ukraine kommen können sie nicht abweisen
das ist Punkt 1 dass ich hier nicht alle
europäischen Länder so verhalten wie man
es erwarten könnte ist eine andere Frage
Österreich beispielsweise ist
vorbildlich in der Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen danke sehr das will ich
sagen aber genau habe ich immer gesagt
die einzige Möglichkeit die
Flüchtlingsproblematik zu beenden ist
Frieden zu finden
und das zweite ist wenn man so viel in
neurophil power reinlegen würde hin das
Nachrüsten auch in das überlegen wie man
vielleicht Friedensverhandlungen führen
könnte und was dazu
stehen russische Truppen vergewaltigen
Frauen plündern und ziehen barbarisch
durch die Gegend das können Sie
natürlich bestreiten und niemanden
hatte das nicht bestritten
nicht machen und jetzt folgendes ich
habe bei mir zu Hause Leute aus der
Ukraine aufgenommen ja ich habe ein Haus
vorbildlich noch nicht vorbildlich das
sage ich Ihnen deshalb ich mache ganz
andere Sachen auch nicht die auch
vorbildlich sein könnten aber
zwei Kinder sieben und elf Jahre der
elfjährige geht in die Schule ging
relativ schnell in die Schule der bringt
bereits jetzt dem Lehrer wir haben es
nicht glauben
it bei der beherrscht besser den
Computer als der Lehrer und seine
Mitschüler wir sollten mal nicht so
hochnäsig sein hier am besten und sagen
wir hängen nämlich aus der Ukraine
kommen will ja wissbegierige sehr
interessierte junge Leute verstanden sie
haben Ukraine Flüchtlinge bei sich auf
ja eine Familie Frau mit zwei Kindern
wohnt bei mir seit Monaten so und das
bedeutet dann mache ich gar kein Ding da
ist okay es ist so ride weil ich selber
Flüchtling Mal war ich weiß es ist Zeit
aber die Situation ist hier
gleichzusetzen mit irgendwelchen die
muss ich sehr vorsichtig sein dass ich
gegen hier nicht gegen korrektes
verstoße mit jungen Männern die sagen
wir mal aus Nordafrika kommen und
zwischen 25 35 sind gut gebaut und sind
noch nicht hungrig aus die dann hier
nach einem Jahr Asyl abgelehntem Antrag
Duldung bekommen und dennoch kein
sozusagen keine Anstalten machen sich zu
integrieren da sehe ich eben schon ein
Unterschied zu denjenigen die aus der
Ukraine zu uns kommen zwei Drittel sind
Frauen zwischen 25 mit kleinen Kindern
alle kommen irgendwann mal in unser
Gesundheitssystem wenn ich ganz kurz mal
da eingreifen kann und da bin ich
nämlich kurz vorbei Herrn Frank wieder
haben Sie das Gefühl dass unser
Gesundheitssystem das ja nun durch
Corona und ähnliches eh schon ziemlich
angeschlagen ist durch den
Fachkräftemangel den Pflegekräftemangel
und ähnlichem die ganze Abwanderung
glauben sie dass wir das dann noch
stemmen können dass wir jetzt zusätzlich
noch Millionen Flüchtlinge auch noch mit
in unser Gesundheitssystem integrieren
jetzt machen sie ein ganz großes Fass
auf Gesundheitssystem ist
ein Haifischbecken das hat ist es mit so
vielen Interessen überlagert und wenn
wir das Gesundheitssystem mal in Ordnung
bringen könnten dann wäre das auch kein
Problem
entsprechende Kriegsflüchtlinge
ordentlich zu versorgen das wäre
überhaupt kein Problem wir haben
Gesundheitsprobleme eher das Problem ich
will es gar nicht Corona sprechen dass
wir eine völlige Vergeltung von
Ressourcen haben dass wir eine
übertherapien haben dass wir tatsächlich
viel zu viel Intensivbetten zum Beispiel
haben dass wir viel zu viel ja wir haben
zu viele insofern
alle das sagen alle die wirklich nicht
krank sind zwischen ambulant und
stationär also die wirklichen Fachleute
ja wir haben es liegen es kommt komplett
die falschen Leute wir haben zum
Beispiel wer liegt denn zum Beispiel auf
intensivabteilungen oft das sind
Menschen die kommen aus Altersheim weil
man dort aus Personalmangel und
Ressourcenmangel quasi mit mehr Pflege
nicht zurechtkommt und dann werden die
teilweise intensiv versorgt was wiederum
hervorragend abzurechnen ist ich sage
Ihnen ganz böses Wort wir sind teilweise
die cash cows im Krankenhaus also wir
haben strukturelle Riesenprobleme sind
einfach teurer die kann man besser
abrechnen und deshalb wir haben doppelt
wir haben doppelt so viel jetzt weiß ich
nicht genau die Zahlen ich habe doppelt
so viel wie wenig Schweiz und dreimal so
viel wie ich war aber wir haben die
wirklich mit Abstand wir haben ja
als die Schweiz also
im Verhältnis also wir sind da ganz in
der also wir haben das ist ein ganz da
müssten wir jetzt eine eigene Sendung
drüber machen aber an den Flüchtlingen
liegt es nicht wenn unser System
überlastet ist es liegt aber glaube ich
ihrer Meinung nach zumindest auch nicht
an Corona sie sagen nämlich vor Corona
müssen wir eigentlich gar keine Angst
mehr haben höchstens noch Respekt und
sie möchten auch ganz gerne eigentlich
ein paar Leute vielleicht sogar vor
Gericht bringen eventuell Jens Spahn ich
bin mal ganz gespannt auf Ihre These
bitte legen Sie los
in der corona-krise wurden meiner
Meinung nach Verbrechen begangen
teilweise gegen die Menschlichkeit und
die Verursacher dieser Verbrechen müssen
vor Gericht gestellt werden
die das fokussiert auf den Lockdown auf
die kurvit Impfkampagne und den Ursprung
des Virus andere Länder beginnen diese
Debatte sie fangen an darüber zu
diskutieren über die Unsinnigkeit des
lockdowns über die Verantwortlichkeiten
wie Großbritannien die Premierministerin
von Alberta in Kanada entschuldigt sich
für impfdiskriminierung und will sie per
Gesetz verbieten dass Supreme Court in
New York
rehabilitiert Polizeibeamte und
Feuerwehrleute die standhaft geblieben
sind sich nicht haben impfen lassen und
ortet jetzt an dass die
wiedereingestellt werden und der Lohn
auch ausgezahlt wird also in anderen
Ländern ist die Debatte vor den Gange
nur wir halten die Leute weiterhin im
waren
betreiben angstpr Propaganda ohne Ende
indem zum Beispiel auch
behauptet wird dass Covic nach wie vor
die Krankenhäuser belastet das stimmt
nicht seit Omegon gibt es quasi keine
echten covid-kranken mehr das sagen alle
Lungenärzte zum Beispiel Thomas vossa
auch der Präsident der pneumologischen
Kliniken das führt so weit dass wir
heute
herztote Krebs tote mit einem PCR-Test
um etikettieren völlig unwürdig um
Abrechnungssysteme zu optimieren die
fließen dann heute in die in die
sterbetal-statistik ein und haben wir in
Deutschland den zehnten Teil aller
weltweiten kurvitote also haben wir hier
eine killervariante die vor der Grenze
halten
kann also eigentlich werden wir von
unserer Politik komplett an der Nase
rumgeführt und Karl Lauterbach erzählt
total ein Schwachsinn eigentlich gibt es
viel zu viele Intensivbetten und Corona
ist eigentlich beobachten extra Thema
aber das ist definitiv so dass die
kovid-epidemie seit Omegon vorbei ist
und wir haben schon relativ viel wenn
ich nur mal in meinem eigenen
Freundeskreis schaue da sehe ich schon
sehr sehr viele Menschen die sich immer
noch mit Kurve anstecken und die
teilweise auch wirklich schwere Verläufe
ganz seltsamerweise ging die Inzidenz
der kurveterkrankungen mit der
Impfkampagne nach oben komisch oder aber
jedenfalls fakt ist wir haben den
zehnten Teil aller kurvitoten weltweit
wie kann das sein haben wir eine
killervariante die an der Grenze aufhört
oder haben wir vielleicht die
kielervariante die in Wirklichkeit Karl
Lauterbach heißt wirklich also und jetzt
wird immer noch einer drauf gesetzt
jetzt werden die Kinder und Säuglinge
wird die Impfung freigegeben diese
covidimpfung und die haben 0,0 nutzen
und täglich kommen Studien rein die die
Gefährlichkeit dieser Impfung weiter
andeuten wie zum Beispiel sind Basel 800
Mitarbeiter der Kliniken boosterimpfung
5% haben ein erhöhtes Troponin das ist
ein Wert der nur bei einem Herzschaden
hoch geht ich hätte mich jetzt
eigentlich nicht impfen lassen sollen
ich bin mehrfach ich bin dreimal geimpft
ich bin auch zweimal gelesen sagen sie
das hätte ich lieber nicht machen soll
einer vernünftigen Abwägung wie sind der
Patienten Kater der Bundesregierung
festgelegt ist hätte man sie informieren
müssen erstens über den Charakter der
Zulassung die ist nämlich bedingt und
deswegen experimentell zweitens hätte
man ihn Ihr Risikoprofil erklären müssen
dass gegen Null geht ja also null ist im
übertrieben aber bei Kindern ist es null
sie haben überhaupt wenig zu befürchten
von kovit aber sie haben eine Impfung
zu lassen es kommt auf die Vorerkrankung
an das will ich jetzt hier nicht
erfragen wenn ich in der Sprechstunde
man kann individuellen Fällen hätte man
vielleicht
sehr kontrolliert mit genauen
Vergleichsgruppen für Risikogruppen die
Impfung anwenden können um zu schauen
was passiert und aber dann rechtzeitig
zu merken dass Alarm wir lassen das mal
lieber aber man hat einfach auf die
Bevölkerung losgelassen aber Fakt ist ja
nun auch das bevor es die Impfungen gab
hatten wir unheimlich viele Menschen die
gestorben sind die auf den
Intensivstationen lagen die beatmet
wurden und eben danach nachdem wir
gegeneinander
wirklich mal was sagen
irgendwo mit unseren
schwerkranke
so nach zweieinhalb Jahren so emotional
zu argumentieren ohne Zahlen zu bringen
Fakten zu bringen ist einfach belämmert
ich habe Verwandte in dieser Richtung
gehabt
wenn Sie eine epidemiologische Bewertung
einer Krankheit machen können sie nicht
mit Einzelbeispielen kommen ich habe
Patienten die die sterben ich habe
Patienten die krank sind wir haben nicht
nur kurvit 19 und es wenn wir einfach
die Fakten sehen wir haben bitte lassen
Sie jetzt die Fakten sagen ja die stehen
auf der Homepage des
Bundesgesundheitsministerin ich sag's
dir weil jeder Sendung wir hatten eine
und nicht Dramatik an der historische
Unterbelegung der Krankenhäuser und der
intensivabteilungen und deshalb zwei
Jahren ist durchgeht
früher 2020 historische das können Sie
nachlesen das ist Fakt wir hatten ich
habe Fakten nachgelesen und es gab
Zeiten wo unsere Intensivbetten komplett
ausgebucht waren und Menschen die
Herzinfarkte oder ähnliches hatten und
einen intensivbett gebraucht haben keins
bekommen haben als Journalistin nicht
gemacht sie müssen die gesamte so nicht
sagen aber das sage ich ganz sicher sie
müssen hier die Gesamtzahlen sehen und
die Gesamtzahlen sind eindeutig dass er
die Leipzig böse gezeigt während ein
historische Unterbelegung und zwar 13%
weniger Patienten waren
hingestellt und gesagt wir haben ein
riesiges Problem wir haben nichts
bezahlen argumentiert ich habe letztes
Mal eine einen Kardiologen von der
Charité hier gehabt
nein lassen Sie sich mal die
Belegungszahlen geben von 2019 18 20 21
und Sie werden staunen sie werden staune
die Krankenhäuser haben sich eine
goldene Nase verdient an leeren Betten
und an der Panikmache von kurvig Kurve
und jetzt behaupten sie dass wir es
weiterhin viele kurvitote haben das sind
keine kovi Toten und wenn wir zehn
Prozent
oder einer Intensivbetten da kann man
jetzt ja mit wir sind durcheinander also
da müssen wir einfach Analyse sagt
eindeutig es gab wie immer im Winter
punktuelle Überbelastungen aber es gab
immer freie Betten das ist die
Normalität sie können nicht für jede
winterepidemie ausreichend für jedes
lokale Krankenhaus und ein normales war
wieder was anderes als unter
okay nach dem Impfen ist es wieder auf
dem Normalzustand gegangen oder ist es
unterbelegte sondern Unterschied ja also
die die Inzidenzen die die die Norm also
nicht krankenhauspflichtigen
Infektion ging seltsamerweise mit der
Impfung steil nach oben dort bei der
Bundeswehr zum Beispiel und wir hatten
aber de facto keine außergewöhnliche
medizinische Belastung durch Kurve das
ist Fakt das kann ich belegen und es
wird einfach nicht in den Medien
diskutiert vielleicht was falsch ist
ich habe viel schon gehört von
Medizinern aber
andere Leute
propagieren und dann welche Werte
unverschämt persönlich jetzt auf die
Belegungszahlen zu nennen 2018/20
die haben damals nicht impfen lassen
damals und kein Mundschutz damals in den
Krankenhäusern nicht wir haben hier
haben Standards und wir haben hier ein
Vergleiche Studien wir haben die
randalisierte kontrollstudie und die
wurde mit Füßen getreten wir haben
keinerlei solide Wissenschaft betrieben
um wirklich mal klare Sicht zu bekommen
auf die Situation und nach zweieinhalb
Jahren haben wir die hatten Daten ich
möchte die hatten da ich möchte ganz
kurz mal zum Leben zum Impfen kommen
wenn sie das nicht so anderen würden sie
sich noch mal impfen lassen oder eher
nicht
ich würde gerne etwas sagen sehr gerne
also ich hatte schon mal vor zwei Jahren
das Vergnügen mit Ihnen zusammen in der
Talk Sendung zersetzen haben sie mir
unterstellt tatsächlich ich würde Fake
News verbreiten weil nein habe ich nicht
auf die immer Datenbank verwiesen habe
und auch sehr sehr gesamt
reality ein anderer ein Wissenschaftler
an Physiker hat mir auch Fake News
unterstellt in der anderen Sendung weil
er geleugnet hat dass es eine bedingte
Zulassung ist nach nach einer Verordnung
die könnte ich hier auch runterrattern
darum geht es gar nicht was ich hier
erlebe ist für mich echt erstaunlich
weil in anderen Staaten ist die
aufklärungssituation schon längst weiter
in Amerika in den USA in dem Land in dem
sie gelebt haben haben sich einige
Bürgerinitiative zusammengetan und haben
die CDC und die FDA verklagt und haben
es geschafft die kaiserdokumente des
ersten Schadens Berichts seit Beginn der
Impfkampagne herauszuklagen jetzt ist es
so dass die jede Woche jeden Monat 500
Seiten auf eine Website hochladen und
sich jeder Mensch die angucken kann und
stellen sich vor ich habe es getan und
wissen Sie was eine der wichtigen
Nebenwirkungen ist neben ganz
schrecklichen Dingen die bei Säuglingen
abgelaufen sind neokaditis und
Thrombosen und Hirnschläge es ist
wirklich grauslich covid 19
ist einer der Nebenwirkungen steht im
Pfizer Bericht ich glaube februar und
die FDA wusste es das bedeutet das
wusste die amerikanische Regierung und
wenn es Peiser wusste dann gehe ich
davon aus dass wenigstens der Kollege
drüben in Mainz es auch wusste und dann
auch das bundesgesundheit also wir sehen
hier und das sind Fakten
deutschen Medien ein ganz harter
Aufschlag bevorsteht wenn sie wieder
Wirklichkeit wirklich mal sich
konfrontiert ich glaube wenn sie mal die
hatten Daten sie an ich kann sie in
demonstrieren wir können sie nachher
anschauen
viel diskutiert auch in unserem
offensichtlich haben wir hier zwei
Wahrheiten also die eine die eins sitzt
und eine andere die in der Welt
herumläuft das kann ich so jetzt nicht
sagen weil ich wenn die wenn die
krankenhausbelegung zweieinhalb Jahre
historisch tief ist
wo ist dann die gefährliche Pandemie
frage ich sie jetzt kann man durch sagen
verschobene Operationen und so weiter ja
das ist aber wenn Sie diese unglaublich
gefährliche Pandemie haben dann müssen
sie trotzdem an an das Limit kommen der
krankenhausbelegung es war nie der Fall
wir hatten zu 13 Prozent Unterbelegung
durchgehend und dann muss man doch
irgendwann mal nachdenken wir haben 2020
ein mildes Sterbejahr gehabt und das ist
Fakt und dann muss man doch mal
nachdenken dass das diskriminiert doch
überhaupt keine kurvitoden jeder
Zusammenleben aber es wird nun mal
gestorben auf intensiv und da muss
gucken an an was wie kann man es
verhindern und haben wir eine besondere
Situation und sie war bei Kurve 19 nicht
gegeben ist eine Erkrankung er hat ein
paar interessante Aspekte es hängt aber
dem Ursprung zusammen das Virus ich
würde jetzt soweit aber es war niemals
die außergewöhnliche Bedrohung gewesen
das ist einfach vielleicht auch daran
dass es jetzt einfach darum der Virus
auch ein bisschen mutiert ist dass wir
jetzt haben
also jetzt ist ja was ich halt
verglichen jetzt kann man es vergleichen
mit einer normalen Grippe also schon
seit Omegon was ich halt auch unfair
finde ist ich bin auch gleich fertig
dass man einfach die ganzen
Nebenwirkungen die ganzen Impfschäden
unter den Tisch fallen lässt also so tut
als ob das überhaupt gar keine geben
also das ist entnehmen Wirkung gibt das
wird nicht unter das wird nicht unter
den Tisch geklärt es gibt eben
bei allen anderen auch bei allen anderen
gibt es Nebenwirkungen
ich glaube dass diese Debatte weder
einen überzeugt der vor einer anderen
Meinung hatte noch umgekehrt es geht
hier um
spielersprüche der eine behauptet dass
der andere das ich persönlich habe viel
mir fehlt der Einblick und das Wissen
das wirklich abwesend beurteilen zu
können ich habe nur ich höre die
Meldungen Florida z.B ist es jetzt
verboten eminema Impfstoffe so weiter zu
verabreichen aufgrund von Nebenwirkungen
aus der us-bundestand
Leute dann sind Texas auch ne sag mal so
wie die Pfeile
in Amerika zu
Vorwurf und da muss ich ihnen das sagen
jetzt erworben erhoben worden der
Begriff Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit
Verbrechen gegen den Menschen ist in
Nürnberger Prozess geboren worden als
eine neue Strafrechts Kategorie nach dem
Holocaust und den schlimmen Verbrechen
die geschehen sind während des Zweiten
Weltkrieges durch Deutschland und
deswegen muss ich sie wirklich fragen ob
sie soweit gehen sie müssen sich der
Dimension ihres Vorwurfs und das meine
ich nicht mal unbedingt nur persönlich
voll Bewusstsein wenn sie behaupten hier
sind Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
vorgekommen müssen Sie dies in der
Öffentlichkeit auch ausfechten ich hoffe
Sie sind sich dessen
bewusstweite darf ich Ihnen zwei
Beispiele ja zum Beispiel
der 70-Jährige Mann
legt mit Herzinfarkt im Krankenhaus hat
ein positiven PCR-Test
ist als isoliert darf nicht besucht
werden seine Ehefrau ist nicht geimpft
und seine Verwandtschaft darf ihn auch
nicht besuchen er muss alleine sterben
das ist ein Verbrechen obwohl das
medizinisch nicht gerechtfertigt ist die
kinderimpfung wir haben wir haben hier
überhaupt grausam wir haben hier aber
wir haben hier haben
wir haben 0,0 Apple wir haben
0,0,0 Nutzen zu erwarten für die
kinderimpfung weil die Kinder von Komet
überhaupt nicht bedroht sind aber wir
haben glasklare bei Hinweise wie schwer
die Nebenwirkungen sind die Kinder
können wenn es schlimm läuft wir wissen
es nicht die Kinder können ihr Leben
lang darunter leiden aber Kinder über
kinderimpfungen
persönlich sagen wer ich verklage ich
verklage Jens Spahn und ich verklage
auch die restliche Bundesregierung und
im auch noch gerne Lauterbach mit dazu
wenn Juristen wenn
man ganz kurz reden ich bin natürlich
Arzt und kein Jurist nach meinem
Rechtsempfinden wurden Verbrechen
begangen aber das müssen natürlich
Juristen feststellen wenn ich also jetzt
Juristen finde sind eine intellektueller
sie müssen doch ein Grundwissen haben
über die Dinge aber das kann man das
bedeutet versprechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit
Europäischen Gerichtshof Beispiel heute
meine Sprechstunde heute ja ein
50-jähriger Mann Kraftfahrer
zweimal t geimpft nach der zweiten
Impfung hat er schon Abend nicht mehr
gespürt ja dann ging es weiter
unerträgliche Schmerzen heute sind seine
Muskulatur zurückgegangen kein Arzt hat
ihn ernst genommen er sagt das kommt von
Dave ich weiß es und ich habe genau
diese Symptomatiken jetzt schon 50-fach
gehört von Patienten diese
muskelproblematiken Schwächeanfälle
Krämpfe und dergleichen
der wurde da wurde sogar von einem Arzt
gesagt das bilden sie sich ein das sind
Tennisarm müssen wir operieren hat
operiert nichts hat geholfen dann war in
der Reha eine Oberärztin hat gesagt
hinter der war so ja ich das kommt von
der Impfung im Bericht stand es nicht
drin was ist das frage ich aber jetzt
haben wir doch gar nicht grundsätzlich
von meinem Arzt geimpft worden damit
seinen armsteifelt
erstens erstens das
Infektionsschutzgesetz also die ganze
Voraussetzung für die bedingte Zulassung
war nicht gegeben weil die
Außergewöhnlichkeit der Situation gar
nicht da war zweitens die Leute wurden
nicht ausreichend aufgeklärt es wurde
ihnen nicht gesagt und bedingte
Zulassung es wurde ihnen nicht gesagt
dass es erhebliche Sicherheitsbedenken
gibt an der krankenkassenzahlen anhand
der abrechnungsziffern der Krankenhäuser
und so weiter und das ich weiß ob das
vorsätzlich ist ich weiß nur dass es
nicht okay ist und zwar gar nicht okay
also was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann
ist das verschwiegen wurde was in dieser
schadensberichten drin stand und man hat
auch behauptet es gäbe eine sterile
Immunität man hat den Leuten gegenüber
gesagt es wäre nebenwirkungsfrei und
jetzt haben wir tote also entschuldigung
ich würde das gerne an dieser Stelle
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen einfangen
denn ich glaube wir verrennen uns hier
ein bisschen in diesem Thema und ich
glaube wir sind jetzt alle auch ein
bisschen zu aufgeregt zu schlecht
gelaunt vielleicht sollte man einfach
auch mal ein bisschen mehr lachen sich
ein bisschen mehr freuen und eventuell
auch diese ganzen krisenprobleme einfach
mal weglachen das sagt nämlich Herr
Gaffron ich bin mal gespannt auf Ihre
These ich
bin der Auffassung dass ins Grundgesetz
ein weiterer Artikel gehört und zwar
gleich nach Artikel 1 dass die Menschen
das Recht auf gute Laune haben denn ich
habe hier in Deutschland das Gefühl
langsam das Lachen verdächtig ist denn
ich habe viele Jahre im Ausland in den
Vereinigten Staaten in Südamerika in
Osteuropa es kann wirklich sagen ich
habe viele Menschen unterschiedlichste
Art kennengelernt wenn man durch
Deutschland durch Berlin geht am Morgen
beispielsweise die Menschen haben alle
verkniffene Gesichtern hat den Eindruck
es ist ein Volkstrauertag das ganze Jahr
und das in einem der wirklich
wohlstandsländer dieser Erde es herrscht
auch überhaupt kein offenes
kommunikationsklima es gibt so etwas wie
nicht wie ich in Frankreich erlebt habe
im Sommer oder Italien so eine
kommunikative Leichtigkeit im Umgang
miteinander in Österreich ist es
übrigens auch der Fall das wundert mich
mögen diesen den deutschen ja ansonsten
nicht so fern auch wenn sie sich wahren
wollen aber insofern bin ich also über
diese komische depressive ich habe den
Eindruck ich kam nun aus Thailand das
Land des Lächelns zuletzt war ich in
Thailand bevor er in vielen anderen
Ländern als Unternehmer mit einer Firma
ich habe also keine Zeit zum Jammern
gehabt so und ich muss da anpacken jeden
Tag um Kohle zu machen uns ganz klar zu
sagen und auch meinen Job zu machen ich
finde hier in Deutschland haben wir eine
Missstimmung und Unfreundlichkeit und
das dazu kommt etwas anderes ich habe
nachgedacht vorher liegt das kann ja
nicht am alten Germanen tun mit der Mann
ich habe eine Unfall an
allensbach-analyse gelesen nach der zwei
Drittel der Deutschen das ist viel sich
nicht mehr trauen ihre Meinung offen zu
sagen und zwar zu Genderfragen zu Fragen
der Nation und andere dann irgendwo muss
es hier so etwas wie ein stilles
Schweigegebot im Land geben das
irgendwelche Leute Silvano di Lorenzo
der bekannte Mann von der Zeit hat
gesagt das öffentliche rechtliche
Fernsehen verbreitet Positionen und
Meinung die von der überwiegenden
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung nicht gedeckt
wird und das macht schlechte Laune nein
das macht den Menschen schlechte Laune
wir haben nein sie kriegen einen
Konflikt und ihre eigene Persönlichkeit
wenn ich einer Frau ein Kompliment mache
bin ich schon ein toxischer Mann ist das
so also
völlig anderen Menschen in der Regel
selbstständige Unternehmer die haben gar
nicht die Zeit sich mit euch man könnte
also wenn ich sie richtig verstehe heißt
das ja dann auch in Zeiten wie diesen
auch wenn wir eigentlich nicht so viel
zu lachen haben könnte man die Krise ja
auch ein bisschen weglachen ihr ein
bisschen Schwung sehen Sie das Aussehen
und dann läuft das schon ja das mit dem
positiven Denken läuft schon da kann man
sich schon hocharbeiten sie haben gesagt
jeder Mensch hat ein Recht auf Glück das
ist glaube ich eine Verfassung in der
USA finde ich auch hier ganz ganz
berechtigt weil dann würde sich
tatsächlich auch jeder dann wird sich
die die Politik auch um das Glück der
Bevölkerung kümmern und ich persönlich
kann ihn nur Recht geben in ganz
wichtiger Faktor ist Freiheit
ich kann nicht ich behaupte das nicht
ich bin nur beobachtet
ganz kurz ich möchte einmal den Arzt
fragen wie wichtig ist gute Laune für
eine gesunde Seele
ja natürlich extrem wichtig wobei sie
muss darf natürlich nicht aufgesetzt
sein ich muss ein Grund haben und viele
das wissen wir ja viele Beschwerden in
einer stadtpraxis ja sind
psychosomatisch vielleicht sogar 70 80
Prozent und das spielt das ist der große
Rolle aber es tut mir leid ich muss da
noch mal auf das panikpapier das
Bundesinnenministeriums verweisen
anfangs der März Anfang 20 ja 2020 wo
explizit panikgeschwürde wurde wurden
Medien vorgemacht vorgeschrieben worden
quasi sollen den Erstickungstod der
Großeltern darstellen dass die Kinder
sich verantwortlich richtig übel und
wenn wir heute die Leute so griesgrämig
werden wenn heute heute
wahnsinnig wenn der Körper schwer krank
dass die Gegend Panik geht
nein das sagen Sie was richtiges da muss
man wissen aufpassen dass wir da das
nicht in die andere verzweifelt die
Leute das Gefühl geben sie haben
Zeitbombe das ist auch übertrieben aber
aber unterbrochen
langweilig ich werde dich gleich traurig
weil ich dafür ausreden
lassen
ich glaube dass die Leute schon
besonders gerade besorgt sind über die
Situation das mag übertrieben sein oder
auch nicht aber ich glaube es gibt
Anlass und ich sage dazu immer also
darum geht weil sie gesagt haben man
kann niemand jetzt überzeugen der ihn
zur verhärtet ist in seiner Position ist
aber man kann wenn man andere überzeugen
will zumindest zeigen dass es bei sich
schöner zugeht das ist besser zugeht
dass man mehr Freude miteinander hat und
hat ein Kollege einen schönen Vergleich
gebracht er sprach vom Harry und
sallye-effekt aha was ist denn der Harry
und Sally wenn sie den Film gesehen
haben aus den 80er Jahren so die Jungs
Komödie und sitzen beide das Paar eben
im Diner und sie sagt viele Frauen
Spielende Orgasmus vor und und Harry
sagt nein das würde ich erkennen und
dann fängt sie an es war richtig
eine der berühmtesten wunderbar und dann
ist sie fertig nimmt sie ein Salat und
die Dame am Nebentisch sagt zum Opa ich
hätte gerne genau gern das auch und das
zeigt einfach wenn ich jetzt jemand
nicht überzeugen kann ich kann ihm mal
zeigen wo uns geht's lustiger zu
freundlicher zu und kommt und irgendwann
wenn die wenn die anderen die
Wirklichkeit immer noch ablocken und
immer noch glauben wir haben die
Wahnsinns Pandemie ist alles so
gefährlich
dann sagen sie irgendwann mal das will
ich auch haben ich will mal raus aus
meinem aus meiner übertriebenen Angst
und vielleicht hat er da vielleicht
in diesem einen Punkt also ich
neige nicht zu Verallgemeinerungen aber
ein bisschen ist es schon ein deutsches
Problem
weil die Freiheit in Österreich ist
genauso eingeschränkt und nicht
eingeschränkt wie hier ja die Freiheit
in Amerika ist alle für größer ja und in
Italien wo die Leute mehr besser
aufgelegt sind positive
aber warum das würde ich so nicht sagen
historisch begründet ich glaube nicht
ich glaube das einfach durch diese ganze
Krisen Geräte des permanente ja alles
ist eine Krise alles ist furchtbar
Leverkusen geht zugrunde die Leute
sterben an der Impfung
alles ist furchtbar ja wie soll sich
denn der einfache Mensch dagegen wehren
außer dass er Angst hat und schlecht
Gela lassen wir die Leute doch ein
bisschen Leben da geben wir in der
Zukunft mehr Freiheit für mehr Freude
für und dafür brauchen die Menschen
Hoffnung sie brauchen Hoffnung dass es
gut wird und diese Hoffnung wird Ihnen
leider glaube ich im Moment sehr sehr
stark genommen
wir haben in Deutschland so tolle Leute
und wenn man die mal wieder mal mehr ran
lassen würde dann würde glaube ich ganz
schnell der vielleicht sogar einen Ruck
hier Herzog meinte durchs Land gehen und
die Leute würden Hoffnung führen die
Probleme als helfen Sie uns das ist die
Realität Freude am Schmerz aber sie
brauchen nein aber sie brauchen
Ohrenschmerzen
sondern ich möchte das Schlusswort
Hoffnung nehmen wir brauchen mehr
Hoffnung damit kann ich eigentlich diese
Runde wunderbar abschließen können wir
dann auch noch mal an die Regierung
weitergeben also hier wird sich
gewünscht von unserer Bundesregierung
geben Sie uns ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung
bisschen mehr Optimismus dann läuft das
vielleicht auch vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns waren dankeschön fürs zuschauen bis
zum nächsten Mal bei 8:15 Uhr schönen
Abend
[Musik]